In the ever-expanding DC Extended Universe,
there are a number of storylines, plot points,
and narrative threads that have disappeared
without explanation. It doesn't mean they'll
never return, of course, but for now these are all
major unfinished business for the growing DCEU.
The film that kicked off the DCEU as we know it
was "Man of Steel." It followed the evolution of
one Clark Kent, played by Henry Cavill, from
small town American alien boy to becoming
Superman. In the process he faces villains from
his long lost Kryptonian heritage. Primarily,
General Zod, played by Michael Shannon,
and his renegade soldiers after they escape
from imprisonment in the Phantom Zone. Zod's
genocidal plan was to use The World Engine,
Kryptonian technology that can terraform a world
into one inhabitable for Kryptonians, on Earth.
The result would be an Earth remade in the image
of Krypton and suitable for Kryptonian life,
but at the cost of its existing life. Zod's
own ship, the Black Zero, contributed towards
the terraforming on one end of the planet with
the World Engine sitting over the Indian Ocean.
Here's the thing: the terraforming process would
affect all life on Earth including the oceans,
and the World Engine was operating
directly over the Indian Ocean.
We know from DC history and "Aquaman" that the
Atlanteans are extremely sensitive to changes in
or mistreatment of the world's oceans.
Also, they have strong weaponry and
technologically advanced vehicles. Given what
we know, there's no reason why they wouldn't
respond to the World Engine, perceiving it as
an attack against their seas and sovereignty.
While Superman did halt its efforts somewhat
quickly, it's surprising they didn't react.
Where were they that was more pressing
than this terraforming attack?
"Batman v Superman: Dawn of Justice" is the first
DCEU film to incorporate the Dark Knight himself,
folding Batman in after he's spent 20 years
fighting crime in Gotham. At this point,
Batman, played by Ben Affleck, is a hardened
and more violent vigilante—even taking to
branding criminals, and he works alone with
the help of Alfred. When we see the Batcave,
one of its more haunting pieces is a
damaged Robin costume in a glass case
with "HAHAHA JOKE'S ON YOU BATMAN"
spray-painted across the front. There
are bullet holes in the suit, but there's
little in the film to explain its backstory.
We know a few key pieces of backstory from
subsequent comments and films. Harley Quinn's
introduction in "Suicide Squad" lists her as an
accomplice to Robin's murder. This admittedly
causes problems for the intended timelines of
both Snyder and "Suicide Squad" director David
Ayer. Joker has his gold grill in his mouth upon
meeting Harley, but it is said to have appeared as
a result of Batman beating him in retaliation for
Robin's death. If that's the case, when and how
did the Joker actually kill Robin, and what
was Harley's actual relation to that crime?
Talking about the lack of clarity
over Robin's death in the DCEU
highlights exactly how little we know
about Batman's 20-year history of
fighting crime in Gotham. In a telling
line to Alfred, Bruce Wayne laments,
"20 years in Gotham, Alfred. We've
seen what promises are worth.
How many good guys are left?
How many stay that way?"
The line suggests that fellow vigilantes have
fallen, like Robin, and perhaps turned to crime.
In "Suicide Squad" we see Killer Croc and watch
the Caped Crusader chase Joker and Harley Quinn,
and elsewhere intervene to capture Deadshot.
But other than some vague generalities,
we know almost nothing about Batman's
history in Gotham or with these villains,
nor the vigilantes that have supported his
crusade. Plus, most of the DCEU has moved on
instead of clarifying any of these omissions.
What's the history of this Batman and his
allies and conflicts? How did it contribute
towards his actions in "Batman v Superman"?
“You’re out of your mind, Bruce Wayne!”
In "Justice League," we see the
first war between Earth's forces
and the forces of Darkseid that took place
5,000 years ago. Regardless of the version,
both showed a Green Lantern fighting alongside
Earth's forces, then dying in the battle with
its power ring flying off to find a new Lantern.
Lanterns essentially protect sectors of space,
and will intervene in situations on a
planet they specialize in protecting
from extraterrestrial threats, invasions, and
other space-based attackers. Most importantly,
sectors shouldn't go without a protector, which
is why the ring sought a new Lantern immediately.
So, where were the Lanterns over the last 5,000
years? Where were the Lanterns when Zod and the
Kryptonians attacked Earth in "Man of Steel"?
Where were they when Doomsday emerged in "Batman
v Superman," or especially in "Justice League"
when another extraterrestrial invasion occurred?
These are exactly the sorts of interstellar
conflicts that Green Lanterns are supposed
to respond to. And, while we see Green
Lanterns in an upcoming HBO Max series,
it makes little sense that they'd sit out
these subsequent interstellar assaults.
In "Shazam!" the DCEU opens up
its magical side. In the film,
the Rock of Eternity is said to be the
source of all magic as well as the place
where the Seven Deadly Sins are kept. The
original wizard Shazam and his seven family
members formed the Council of Wizards there. At
some point in the past, Shazam gave Teth-Adam,
later known as Black Adam, powers in that realm.
The conflict pitting Black Adam and the unleashed
Seven Deadly Sins against the Council of Wizards
resulted in the deaths of most of the latter.
Considerable time passed before Shazam transferred
his powers to Billy Batson and later Billy's own
Shazam Family to fight the newly released Seven
Deadly Sins and the villainous Dr. Sivana.
Certainly a lot will be explained about Black
Adam in subsequent films. But in the comics
he began life as an Egyptian slave, putting
the events that killed most of the Council
of Wizards approximately around 5,000 years
ago. This is exactly when the Atlanteans,
Amazons, and early humans fought the forces of
Darkseid in "Justice League." If the Council of
Wizards were around, where were they when evil
alien gods were invading? Gods, Atlanteans,
and Amazons were all there, yet the Wizards didn't
show up to protect the Earth at this pivotal time.
In "Batman v Superman: Dawn of Justice,"
Lex Luthor, played by Jesse Eisenberg,
wages a multi-pronged attack on
Superman. It involved many steps,
from blowing up the United States Capital
to kidnapping Superman's mom. In a moment
of justification he claims that his motivation is
basically being against the notion of 'gods' on
Earth. He argues that devils don't come from hell
beneath us, rather they come from the sky. So,
clearly he sees Superman as an evil enemy. He also
shares his interesting argument of a divine being.
"If God is all-powerful, He cannot be all good.
And if He is all good, then
He cannot be all-powerful."
Ultimately, We aren't really given other reasons
for Luthor to hate Superman. In the comics Luthor
is said to have a long history and personal
vendetta against him. Not so here. The only
reason we have is Luthor's supposed disdain
for "gods" that have power above humans.
Luthor's final plan beyond his convoluted mess of
tactics involves mixing his own blood with Zod's
body, combining the two with Kryptonian technology
to create Doomsday, the ultra-powerful behemoth
that kills Superman. So his motivating
factor is apparently a hatred of gods,
and yet his final plan is to
engineer a god that's more powerful,
more animalistic, and less subject to human
control? That's not what a brilliant planner
would do with that motivation, so what's Luthor's
real incentive for absolutely hating Superman?
Regarding Luthor's engineering of the
Doomsday monster in "Batman v Superman:
Dawn of Justice," the process makes relatively
little sense. Lex enters the Genesis Chamber
of the Kryptonian scout ship using Zod's
fingerprints and command key. He's taught the
wealth of knowledge from the Kryptonian archives,
learning of an ancient Kryptonian monster — aka
Doomsday — that he re-creates as a failsafe if
Batman can't or doesn't kill Superman. The process
involves bringing Zod's corpse into the Genesis
Chamber, then Luthor cutting himself and bleeding
into the Chamber and onto Zod. The resultant
engineering feat is a version of the recreation of
Doomsday. It’s an effectively mindless creature
with immense strength, at least on par with if not
stronger than Superman, boundless rage,
and some serious regenerative abilities.
What makes little sense is why corrupting
Kryptonian DNA with human DNA made such a strong,
if not stronger entity than Superman. Humans
look like Kryptonians in every relevant way, but
Doomsday is larger than either and looks like
neither. Kryptonians are massively stronger
on Earth than humans are, and Doomsday seems
stronger than Kryptonians despite the addition
of human DNA. Adding human DNA wouldn't
be the recipe to make this ancient beast,
because it's unlikely that its ancient
Kryptonian creator had humans lying around.
Why in the world would blending
Kryptonian DNA with human DNA
not make Doomsday a hybrid of the two, thus
weaker than Superman? It makes little sense.
In "Batman v. Superman: Dawn
of Justice," Bruce Wayne is
woken from a nightmare by a vision of Barry Allen,
aka The Flash. He offers Bruce a warning about
the future—albeit vague and confusing—saying,
"Bruce! Listen to me now. It's Lois.
It's Lois Lane. She's the key."
"You were right about him. You've always been
right about him! Fear him! Find us, Bruce!"
In "Zack Snyder's Justice League,"
Superman succumbs to the Anti-Life
equation and under Darkseid's rule
lays waste to many of his enemies.
The Flash, we can infer, went back in time to
warn Batman about Superman's inherent danger.
Of course this was a plot thread that the
DCEU didn't move forward with, so there's a
high chance it will never be fulfilled and we only
see in part where it may have been intended to go.
At the same time, the Flash sequence
still exists within DCEU continuity,
but it is unclear how they're going to try
to give it finality and meaning, if at all.
In "Wonder Woman 1984," the FBI turn to Dr.
Barbara Minerva to aid in the identification of
the wish-granting Dreamstone. Failing businessman
Maxwell Lord wishes to become the stone itself.
It grants him the ability to gain power
every time someone makes a wish through him.
He uses this to eventually take over the White
House, secretive U.S. communications technologies,
and effectively the whole world as
he grants the wishes of humanity.
All these wishes come with a cost to their
users, of course, and it all pushes humanity
nearly to the point of global nuclear war.
Wonder Woman uses her Lasso of Truth on Lord,
convincing the world — including Lord — to
end the crisis by renouncing their wishes.
But even though there's no indication that
renouncing wishes made anyone forget the
events that just occurred on a global scale,
the movie just sort of moves on. If everyone on
Earth was allowed to make wishes that came true,
causing massive global chaos, that would change
human history, civilization, and religion as we
know it. It would reveal the existence of magic,
which is a big deal, and publicly confirm the
existence of metahumans as early as the 1980s. It
would change literally everything in the DCEU, but
instead it was dropped like it wasn't a big deal.
“That’s the truth.”
In "Suicide Squad," Amanda Waller builds a team
of expendable super-villains to go on dangerous
missions in the wake of Superman's death
in exchange for commuted prison sentences.
The main exception is Dr. June Moone, who is
possessed by an ancient interdimensional sorceress
known as Enchantress. When Enchantress and her
ancient brother Incubus move to take over Earth,
the pair use magic to turn a variety of
people into their supernatural soldiers.
The odd thing about all this is that
the villains here are clearly magical,
mystical threats and Waller knows
this. Even still, most of the members
of the “suicide squad” have literally no
mystical abilities or relation to magic.
This is a major oversight, because the only reason
the team succeeds is due to the efforts of its
somewhat magical members. For example, El Diablo
uses his cursed full fire form to fight Incubus
and push him over a bomb. Waller knows Enchantress
is a sorceress, so why send an ill-chosen team
for a magical job? Was the U.S. government so
uninterested in magic that they never bothered to
have good contingency plans against magic attacks?
And have they gotten any better on that front?
Check out one of our newest
videos right here! Plus,
even more Looper videos about your
favorite DC movies are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one.